you're full you're in this for fame you
take advantage of women you're not in
this for
John Paul Jones explodes on Derek over
Taoiseach at Crystal and Chris's wedding
people are in paradise come here
did JPJ and Derek's get us all kicked
out of this wedding annoying
Christel Nielsen and Chris Rand own tied
the knot during Tuesday night's episode
of bachelor in paradise and the turmoil
from the beach he with it's very
difficult to see the woman that you know
you're in love with potentially open up
the door another guy JPJ was struggling
hard after Derek gave his love interest
tisha a rose at the rose ceremony
leaving at JPJ
to hand his out to Haley his anger over
Derek pursuing tisha boiled over during
crystal and Chris's wedding you've also
demonstrated in your experience in using
your status to hook up with women that
are infatuated with public figures Derek
I think that's I think that's
information I know no don't hold on with
me Derek that's you know you don't get
to bulldoze through and after the guys
got back to the beach JPJ reignited the
drama took the trash out
every word I said today you knew I was
into tasting we talked earlier in the
day we tried to just shot about and see
where people were and you didn't mention
her name or give any indication as to
what you were feeling
the bride and groom weighed in on the
awkward situation that went down on
their big day
thankfully you know this happened after
the ceremony right after where they had
a cocktail party unfortunately we were
still taking pictures and doing a lot of
wedding things before we could enter the
cocktail party there was nothing that
would make sense for this argument to
begin with so there's a lot of things
that are thrown out there that make you
question how is this even coming to
light and whose side are you guys on
unless you're very much so derek was
attacked verbally and you know it's
unfortunate to say this but you know JPJ
was very much out of line and very
aggressive and what took place was this
happened in front of my family my mom
saw the whole thing so I knew about this
before even we saw previews but he
attacks Derek in a way where he seems
very narcissistic and a lot of anger
which really scares will probably scare
what in question viewers as to me today
people as far as you know the emotional
stability paradises resident bartender
Wells Adams also chimed in what bugged
me about that fight was there's not a
whole lot of evidence to confirm what
john paul saying about Derek he's doing
saying that Derek is a guy who just
hooks up with girls and that he's not a
good yeah he doesn't respect women and
we saw an incredibly respectful Derek
with Demi just episodes ago so it's very
yeah that's what left-field that's what
I said I was like it doesn't make any
sense to me like so Derek's track record
as he went on the P was on the show with
me and he got dumped by Jojo and then he
went on bachelor in paradise for got
engaged and then factly got dumped again
and then now he comes on this one and he
gets it Neverland I don't know how he if
anything he's a terrible dater
another womanizer from next week's
teaser it looks like things get worse
between these two oh you're messing the
patient
this is just John Paul screwing with
everybody we'll have to stay tuned to
see what goes down more Dom is about to
come out you're pulling you're in this
for fame you take advantage of women
don't get that close to me
you